dans son petit garage de sept-îles
gilles lapierre a imaginé et conçu une
auto neige unique au monde construite en
grande partie à partir de pièces
recyclées le châssis la carrosserie et
l'assemblage des pièces ont entièrement
été réalisé par gilles lapierre avec
l'aide de ses amis
les chenilles les roues et les barbotin
proviennent quant à eux d'une vieille
autoneige bombardier est le moteur d'une
camionnette
la longue carrière de camionneurs de
gilles lapierre lui a permis de se
familiariser à la mécanique à la
mécanique sur les liens appris à tuchan
vous dire là prêts à travailler mon
camion venu le temps mais j'entretiens
mongeau millions qu'a fait des
réparations vais poursuivre dans le
mécanique poteau depuis qu'il est tout
petit j'ai la pierre est fasciné par les
motoneiges et les autos neige
ces véhicules faisait partie de son
quotidien dans sa jeunesse de son petit
village de l'île michon en minganie
il se rendait chaque jour d'hiver à
l'école d'aguanish dans une auto neige
de 12 places
[Musique]
il replonge maintenant dans son enfance
après avoir investi des centaines
d'heures de temps libre à son auto neige
il estime avoir dépensé entre 5 et 6000
$ pour les matériaux nécessaires au
projet une aventure qui aura duré
environ un an et demi j'ai commencé ça
fait tâche à fait d'un nombre d'acteurs
puis t'as pas mal comme y est donc resté
un petit peu de deux meilleures vaches
tout le temps un petit peu au-delà des
reprises des fois reprendre dès sa prime
après un an et demi j'ai lapierre veut
maintenant faire immatriculer son
véhicule pour pouvoir se promet plus
librement avec sa création ici j'avais
annabelle totten radio canada cette île